hello I'm Paul F Tompkins we are at C so
art in the game of mass-produced
inorganic comedy our company comes from
someplace special camera we're working
hard on crafting it art is no type of
comedy first tip always start from a
grounded place all great advice - what
over there okay art is anal comedy is
the only comedy I thought passed these
lips
it's pronounced artisanal so you
brainstorm all these great ideas and you
take these great comedic thoughts things
like pratfalls innuendo double tips and
you distill them all down to its purest
form the joke then you age it right here
in this oak cask we would put salt on
top of the barrel because wasting food
is funny I'll see you in hell welcome to
the kitchen what are you guys cooking up
in here don't do jokes like that don't
do jokes like that it was just for us
we're just in here working on some
physical comedy
let's take a look at the spit take for
example the water used in the spit take
is incredibly important
purified bottled water is fine but the
encapsulated humidity from Amazonian
cloud forests is the best the pie to the
face is another classic example most
processed cream is weak and doesn't hold
together people know the difference
between a pile of wet whipped cream and
the sound of organic flour this comedy
has to be leisurely enjoyed over the
course of a day specifically February
21st our day of ha that's right America
so let's get together sit down for our
day of ha where we're going to
dream our asses